but joining me now for her first
interview battle this is the journalist
at the center of the covid WhatsApp leak
sensation talk TV's International editor
Isabella and we'll talk to you these
political editor Kate McCann Daily
Mirror associate editor Kevin McGuire
Isabel wow but it dropped last night at
10 45. uh it was quite something to read
all this particularly for people like me
who obviously were on air throughout
this pandemic and involved in pretty
heated discussions with people like Matt
Hancock in which frankly they lied
through their back teeth about what was
really going on to see in their WhatsApp
messages the cold hard reality were
shocking
you've had this for a while what made
you I mean let's be brutally honest
about what you did you did a book with
Matt Hancock as part of the preparation
for the book it gives you a hundred
thousand what's that messages between
him and and members of the cabinet the
Prime Minister you don't put them in the
book he says you signed an NDA to stop
you using these and you've now
presumably broken the NDA given these to
the Daily telegrapher publication he
says you've stolen them blah blah blah
what is your reaction to all this well
first of all please I'm very aware of
how robustly uh you fought for public
accountability from our politicians
during this period I can tell you that
your name does crop up in some of these
messages I would hope so I'm sure we'll
come to that later in the week look you
mentioned in your introduction uh the
absolute fast that is the public inquiry
Arrangement so far this public inquiry
if you look at the terms of reference I
could spend a year on each one of about
the 30 things that they have been asked
to consider the judge who is somebody of
the highest integrity and has a great
reputation no doubt will want to do
justice to every one of those things
she's not been given a deadline so the
reality is that this inquiry which I
think is absolutely critical will likely
not come up with any conclusions left to
the government's own devices perhaps for
at least a decade or more now we could
have another pandemic next month next
year who knows when the next one is
coming we cannot afford to wait for a
decade or more for answers as to what
was really going on so this resource
that I had is an extraordinary way to
quickly get to the truth of what really
happened why crucial decisions were made
that affected millions of lives that
millions of people are still paying the
price for today without us having to be
fobbed off with an inquiry which I'm
afraid is most likely going to end up
for the best intentions of everyone
involved being a whitewash so Lord
Bethel who is a health minister at the
time has told Tom Newton done for his
show tonight on talk TV Isabella shot
has no idea what one on those in those
rooms she hasn't seen the paper she's
seen a few whatsapps from around the
edges she's fooling herself if she
thinks that's really given her an
Insight what she's taken is a bunch of
fluff that was in Trans in transient
transient transient I think that means
what's happened messages and pretended
that it's substantive insight into the
evidence-based decision that's been made
is simply not true it's a confection and
quite frankly the telegraph should be
ashamed of themselves what an
embarrassing and pathetic and lame
defense uh from Lord Bethel there I
imagine the battle's rather nervous
because he is one of the most Indiscreet
people in these WhatsApp messages highly
revelatory for him to dismiss them as a
few WhatsApp messages which I heard him
say this morning the entire volume of
this is almost three times the size of
the Bible it's not a few messages and
the reality is that the WhatsApp groups
were used routinely minute by minute to
communicate critical Decisions by the
way there is an argument they should be
public record right I mean in America
every communication like this with a
prime minister with the president would
be public record so you can't do privacy
yeah if he's saying that this is a
partial account I am all he is for the
rest of it and I'm sure that the nature
okay let me be very grateful if all
whatsapps from every Minister involved
were released now your position is that
this is in the public interest 100 let
me just ask you to the specifics which
Hancock has said by word of response did
you sign an NDA which pledged not to use
these messages yes so you've
deliberately broken that I have in the
public interest and they could be there
could be legal consequences the public
interest is overwhelming whenever you
break a big story which is in the
National interest and I've done a few of
them it can be a rocky road it can be a
bumpy ride look I know that I'm going to
get a few knocks over this I'm prepared
to do this because I think that the
national interest is so utterly
compelling another difficult question
the cynic would say well hang on you've
just done this Memoir with this guy
which has enriched him right and in the
Memoir you say that he's very persuasive
and you know you thought he had good
arguments and so on not a sign now of
what you're now saying about it and a
cynic would say well come on Isabelle
you did this Memoir with him why won't
you you more honest if you really felt
this way why not just pull away from
writing the book with him and expose all
this at the time rather than allow this
sham of a book to come out well he
glossed over everything it made him out
to be some kind of hero I think that's
quite unfair I don't know whether you've
read every every word I couldn't get
through all of it well even though it
was so beautifully written by me
actually judging by themselves because
my point being that I'm really happy to
address that yeah because I think it is
an important one
um and the reality is I would of course
not have put my name to anything that I
thought was an untruth the other reality
is that there are nearly three million
words in these WhatsApp messages
I was working on this book against the
clock it was a phenomenal effort it was
twice the length of any normal political
book it was simply impossible to go
through every line of those WhatsApp
messages and of course equally the book
is Matt Hancock's diary it's his truth
when did he know that you've done this
late last night wow what everybody else
did yeah did you have any convulsion at
all about frying a contact like someone
you've written a book with
uh I'm not gonna sit here and uh
disparage Matt Hancock personally
because this is not about well yeah
you've just talked to me for me this is
not about it this is not about you have
as a journalist you've written a book
with this guy and within months of the
book coming out
you've talked right I mean you've fried
the contact you've ripped up the NDA
you've published all the messages I'm
not taking a judgment I'm just saying
you have done that there are many things
I could sit here and say about Matt
Hancock which I'm not going to do now it
seems a good time I'm not going to do
because this for me is not a personal
thing is it true that he is it true that
he went back on his word with you in
relation to your business arrangement
with the book
uh
uh I again I don't want to get into that
he's
he's as International editor of talk TV
he reneged on that it's of course not
the reason why I did this I cannot
emphasize enough this is not personal
against Matt Hancock I can see many good
qualities in him we had a good working
relationship
by and large
um various aspects towards the end we're
not quite have you heard from him since
since the publication of this yes I have
what did he say I received a somewhat
menacing message at 1 20 in the morning
I'm not going to repeat what was in the
message
um but yeah I'm saying menacing what was
well uh I think you can easily surmise
whether Matt Hancock is my friend at
this point oh sure he's not but I mean
what does menacing mean we threatened
you
I I I think that he um is extremely
troubled in terms of how to respond to
this and I I don't blame him but this is
not about him as far as I'm concerned it
is much bigger than that it is about
understanding the truth of what really I
understand that
um specifically he says it's been edited
that there were other WhatsApp exchanges
I think is that he's withdrawn that no
it isn't it's emphatically inaccurate we
specifically refer to that meeting I
think it's on page four of the coverage
he simply hasn't read the inside story
is there any is there any doubt from
everything you've read is there any
doubt at all that the veracity of that
main charge in the telegraph Revelations
today about the care homes and about him
overriding the advice from the chief
medical officer that that is entirely
true there's no doubt in my mind that
what the telegraph of printed today is
an action reflection the telegraph has
been exceptionally careful not to
selectively quote from these messages
look they're not Daft they know that
that would be a very easy stick to beat
them with so they have been very careful
also the telegraph doesn't over claim
for any of this of course we know there
are other people whose conversations we
don't have access to that is entirely
obvious okay
YouTube been sitting here listening to
all this I mean look from a journalistic
point of view I picked I picked up a
telegraph to money there's a sensation I
mean this was extraordinary reading to
go through all this
um I think I'll put the tough questions
to Isabel and she's been robust in
responding from a political point of
view first Katie what has been the
reaction to this and what are the likely
consequences if anything so there have
been a couple of different reactions
clearly Matt Hancock and his team very
very frustrated and unhappy Helen
Whiteley you know a minister who was
sort of talking about this today
suggests that there was a meeting in
between all of this advice being you
know given to Matt Hancock where the
political reality came up against the
scientific advice and I think this has
been a problem all the way through this
story in fact all the way through covid
there is a difference between scientific
advice and the reality of what can
happen on the ground and Matt Hancock's
point would be yes Chris Whitley advised
we do this the capacity wasn't there to
do it therefore you know we were forced
to scale it back and we did it as soon
as we could what I actually think is
that some of the messages in here do
reveal something quite problematic for
the government which is about the way
that Care Homes were not prioritized
Helen weightless messages inside the
telegraph showing her saying we have a
problem with PPE we don't have enough
and I can't get anyone to tell me when I
will have enough and she's asking you
know quite nicely of the of the house I
mean I interviewed Helen Whiteley
several times in that period And I
thought she was completely out of her
depth which I thought summarized my view
of that government a young rookie
government just come in a lot of them
completely out of their debt didn't know
what but then did you change your mind
when you read this because I actually
well I I had a slightly more sympathy
with her that she had clearly been
asking for this stuff but clearly wasn't
getting it back I mean Kevin from well
first of all from a journalistic point
of view
what do you think about what Isabel did
here oh Isabelle's accused of stabbing
Hancock in the in the back and she'll
have to deal with the journalistic
ethics but is there a public interest
defense for that but yes clearly and are
we in a better position tonight than we
were last night on Covert yes we are
that's what I think because she's made
though this has made them public she'll
have to take the uh The Knocks as well
as the uh the praise for that but we get
an incredible insight into what was
really happening what do you feel you
know now you didn't yesterday that he
didn't that Hancock didn't follow always
a scientific advice yes he was Guided by
it at times and it can accept right
covert appears almost from a clear blue
sky it's a huge catastrophe a real
challenge you're making decisions in
real time with resource limitations you
haven't got the organization right so
mistakes will be made but because of
some of those mistakes people died they
died we can't get away from it and by
the way in Care Homes thousands and
thousands of people died I know people
who lost their relatives who lost their
mother their father absolutely in Care
Homes and peers I can see this is very
inconvenient for Matt Hancock because he
he wants to reinvent himself as a lad
locking around on reality TV no doubt
doing a lot of gigs you know at dinners
and so on and getting paid well people
aren't going to be laughing now they're
not and they realize one person who
definitely won't be laughing is the
owner of Crabtree Care Homes David
Crabtree David we've spoken many times
throughout the pandemic and and again uh
in the last few months what is your
reaction to these Revelations about Matt
Hancock in particular in the telegraph
if you go back thank you Peter if you go
back and and thank you for for being a
stowa for the care sector thank you if
you go back to your opening section
where he was speaking he said from the
very start from the very start well from
the very start he lied and he lied and
he lied and he continues to lie it's not
that we got things wrong pandemic was
new to everyone it's that he lied after
the event and continues to lie and what
happens with its lies and all of this
publicity is he reinvoked all the anger
and upset the loss of life the relatives
he risked it wasn't just the elderly he
was risking the mother of two that was
coming to work at seven o'clock with no
PPE everything this man does
is characterized by an inadequate
sociopath everything he does if you look
it up there's his characteristic I wish
to goodness he would just disappear
because he's managed to destroy his own
career is is is his relationships
I I cannot tell you how incensed the
care sector is every time this man's
name is mentioned yeah no I I know I've
heard it from from them myself okay lots
of people's names are in these WhatsApp
messages you know Boris Johnson's there
liberally Rishi sunak we're told is in a
lot of them too Isabel you can confirm
that yeah absolutely so the current
prime minister is I mean they must all
be on ten terms right waiting for the
next installment tonight uh with all
these Revelations this afternoon that
apparently we only follow for example
what Scotland did in relation to kids
wearing masks and stuff because they
didn't want to you know make a problem
with Nicholas sturgeon and Scotland
which seems to be an extraordinary
Revelation never mind anything else yeah
I think it is and actually it's a point
you raise a point that's going to be a
much bigger issue for Westminster now
and it's going to have huge
repercussions today at the lobby
briefing for journalists after prime
minister's questions the questions were
repeatedly about how do ministers use
their phones are they using deletion on
WhatsApp as a regular thing you said
that they should be held to account that
those messages should be public record
they are peers they are public record
except from who is checking that that
happens right now and the Prime Minister
spokesman was asked that today and he
said well there is a policy on this you
are actually as a minister if you are
discussing policy you're allowed to do
that on WhatsApp but you have to then
ensure that it is recorded So that any
official decision which is not allowed
to be made on whats that book can be
discussed is then there as public record
at the moment I'm not sure that the
government can guarantee comfortably
that that I'm sure I'm sure they can't
Isabel are there Revelations to come
which could cause the current prime
minister problems
um I think that the current prime
minister in his capacity as Chancellor
was doing what chancellors should do and
protecting the public purse um nothing
damaging about it I don't want to
comment on what's to come up I'm sure
you'll understand that but I think that
this issue that you raise about the use
of whatsapps goes to the heart of why
it's so important for people to see the
way decisions were made the casualness
the informality of you know a few meets
an incredibly powerful positions with a
thumbs up or thumbs down deciding the
fate of millions of people we look you
can under certain circumstances get them
under a freedom of information request
but worth saying Lord Bethel the health
minister at the time who's had to go at
Isabel there's a sticker for herself he
lost a lot of his WhatsApp messages on
Covert contracts when he was
transferring phones it wasn't quite it
wasn't quite uh wagatha Christie the
phone going over the side of a boat but
nevertheless those messages have been
lost forever so when he has a go on
other people I think hang on Bethel some
of your messages have gone already no
it's it's government by WhatsApp now
Tony Blair used to be by sofa it's
shifted is everyone okay in Westminster
basically waiting for the telegraph to
drop tonight
yeah I think people are and they will be
probably for some time but I do think
that this goes beyond as we're saying
here it's beyond Matt Hancock it's about
how policy is made in this country and I
think it's about the fact that a lot of
these decisions when you read them you
may not look at them and think Wowzer
there's The Smoking Gun but actually
it's more subtle than that it's about
the way that these decisions were made I
just remember the certainty that Hancock
was saying we put a protective ring
around here he did not put a protective
ring around Care Homes he let a lot of
people back from hospital without
testing them up like hospitals were Rife
with covid he let anyone from the
community Come and Go including the
carers including family members to start
with the whole thing was total and what
was the point your guest was making
which was seemingly and I don't know
whether he believes this I don't want to
speak for him but if actually the
government had been honest and said we
we can't do this yet we would love to
we're going to try as soon as we can
well let's ask David Crabtree that
finally that very question David had you
known these issues of the government and
we're now reading about you would have
presumably acted differently
you don't need to be a scientist to know
that you don't admit potentially
infected people into a care home when
Professor Valance in January said these
would be breeding grounds and we watched
it across Italy and France before it
arrived at our doorstep we already knew
to shut the door to try and minimize we
accepted that this was you know there
was a pandemic On and nobody had any PPE
or whatever we did the best we could and
we accept that errors were made what is
the anger is invoked because they now
lie to cover it up we would have coped
as we would cope with diarrhea and
sickness with flu epidemic with all the
others that we normally associate
through winter we're not stupid we've
been doing it a long time we don't need
a scientist what we do need is truth
factual we don't have enough this is
what we're going to do we're going to
try and help you don't lie to us and say
that you put a ring of protection around
us David how many how many people did
you lose in the pandemic from
we lost 8 18 over two homes that's just
us but across Bradford we lost thousands
absolutely shocking it was shocking
David thank you for your your passion
you're always the relatives couldn't the
relatives couldn't go in nobody could
see anybody so people were losing their
loved ones without seeing them it was
awful I know a good friend of mine had
to say goodbye to her beloved mother on
FaceTime
in a car when it ripped through the care
I mean imagine that I still haunts me to
this day thinking about it David thank
you very much indeed for joining me
thank you if if we could just get an
apology off Mr Hancock that would do us
you know what I think you've got more
chance honestly of him handing back the
money from eating kangaroo testicles in
the jungle but a good idea David uh
Isabel I think it's a fantastic scoop uh
there's an argument to be had about
whether it's all the public I think it's
overwhelming in the public interest
um and so I'm looking forward to reading
more Revelations thank you so uh I think
congratulations are in order to you for
exposing this frankly okay thank you
very much for joining me that's gonna be
interesting to see a reaction Tomorrow
there's more Revelations to come back
tonight Hey Kevin you're staying with me
thank you you've got the Short Straw you
two in morning by the way in the
Blackford Hancock's career or yeah
accidental
good to see you